hey guys I'm Charla mossad and does
anyone have any idea what I might be
talking to you guys about today so
really big hint that's right it's this
bad boy this is a brotherhood of steel
helmet and it is easily one of my
favorite things that I own so this one
cost me about $350 plus shipping which
is about $70 from the UK and it also
comes with a stand and cultivate it was
lovely enough to actually give me some
batteries for it so it lights up and
while the eyes are a little bit
spray-painted over you can see out of it
everything's slightly blurry and a lot
darker than normal but you can see
enough to comfortably walk without
bumping into everything
the only flaw with it at this point is
that a little bit of the foam padding on
the inside did fall out but I just sent
a message off to jump punk studios and
they told me how to get a really cheap
adhesive spray so I could fix it myself
so this is the standard edition that
they make they also have a deluxe
edition which I totally would have
gotten if I had a moment it existed that
also includes an amp and a microphone
John Park Studios started making these
by basically accumulating all of the
knowledge that they possibly could on it
and then the helmet was hand sculpted
from clay over the course of a couple of
months after the sculpture was complete
a silicon mold was made of the clay
helmet its then cast from fiberglass
backed with a polyurethane resin the
sanding and cleanup of everything takes
about five to eight hours and after
applying primer and letting it dry the
multi-layered first steel paint scheme
is applied after that any custom
stenciling or distressing is done and
then finally the plumbing being the
tubes and pipes is a plot now if you
simply can't decide if you would want
one of these bad boys or not there's a
couple of ways you can use them for
doing regular stuff like reading for
partying
for cosplay wait a minute
so generally trying to freak people out
so I have an offer to give you guys if
you want one of these or anything else
that jump Park Studios has to offer all
you have to do is put in a discount code
ask for cult put in a discount code when
you go to the website and I'll have a
link below and the discount code is
Alana that's my name I'll see you guys
next time